We're looking for people who just want
to get out there and explore and learn
and have an adventure, you know.  They're
gonna be riding alongside experts in the field.
I wanted to give that kind of visceral
sense of how climate change is
affecting people and ecosystems in California.
and the bike ride seemed like the perfect way to do that.
The name OnePulse shows how we are all
together in this you know and how we can
all come together to solve global issues.
Climate change is a big one and that's
something that we need to address.
We also would like to see how communities
are coping with climate change and what
steps they're taking to
reduce their carbon footprint.
So, it's just a really unique way to experience California
and the impacts of climate change on California.
And I think that that actually might shape the
research that we end up doing.
Becoming a rider with OnePulse is a once in a lifetime experience.
You know,  you'll get to understand
the effects of climate change
You'll actually be supporting the
research by raising funds.
And the views aren't bad.